(rock music fading out)
- All right, oh my gosh.
Give it up for the band!
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh.
I always like to close
out with one last story
I hope that you'll enjoy.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
I'm so excited to now be
living here in New York.
You have no idea.
It's the largest understatement ever,
but I am not the only one.
Y'all are loving it here?
People are having a good time, right?
Yes, yes.
(audience cheering)
All right.
That made me feel really
good when people said that,
'cause this was my decision.
Just could of gone poorly.
A few days ago though,
our Vocal Director, Jessi
had a magical moment
walking down the street.
Our Senior Supervising Digital
Producer, Andy caught it
in its full glory and I
made her let me play it.
Check out this gem Jessi
posted on Instagram.
- Da, da, seven, hit.
It's five, six, seven, eight.
It's a one, two, three.
- [Crowd] Hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey.
- Welcome to New York, baby!
(people cheering)
- My favorite thing ever.
(audience clapping)
She showed me this and
I was like, "Oh my gosh,
"I love New York so much."
What happened?
Those were strangers.
- Those were strangers.
Andy...(laughs)
Andy and I went out for a drink.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But like a place on his block.
And we walked in, we were
just getting like a drink
with his friends that were in town
and we walked in and it
was a full drag show.
So obviously, we stayed.
(audience laughing)
And anyway, so then I left
and we were in the street
and I wasn't sober.
- And you were on a stage.
(audience laughing)
- And I was just practicing
my best drag walk.
And then next thing I know
there was a whole crowd
of people cheering me on.
- I love New York.
- [Jessi] It's the best.
- Those were perfect strangers.
- It's the best.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, Jessi, for
allowing me to play that.
I love it so much.
I'm liking your post right now.
Now around this point
we usually give our guest $1,000
courtesy of our season
long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
And I know that Jess
is like, "Wait, what?"
But sadly, we are not able to give that
to people who work here.
- [Jessi] Oh.
- So I'm gonna buy her a really nice gift.
So, their loss is going to be the gain
for someone in the audience though.
So I want you to look at the monitor
and our cameras are
gonna do a little magic
and one of your faces is
gonna show up right there.
So, okay.
Hit it, let's do it.
(drumroll)
Who's face, who's face, who's face?
(audience cheering)
(exciting music)
Your eyes got so big.
What's your name?
- Louie.
What's up?
What are you gonna do do with the grand?
- Go on vacation with my fiance.
- Yes!
(audience cheering)
I love that.
Well, have such a beautiful life together.
Thank y'all for coming
and congrats on the grand.
- Thank you so much.
We're such huge fans.
We love you.
- Oh, thank you.
I'm a fan of Jessi's right now.
- [Louie] Yes ma'am.
- Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Sam Heughan, Jana Kramer,
Matthew and Grace and Camila.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.